[Música]
terminaron las confrontaciones en la
zona verde de bagdad en irak esto luego
de dos días de choques violentos entre
los seguidores del clérigo múqtada al
sádr contra las fuerzas de seguridad y
los rivales chiítas respaldados por irán
en un nuevo pronunciamiento televisado
al sadar se disculpó el día de ayer por
los al menos 23 muertos que hubo entre
el domingo y el día lunes y ordenó a sus
partidarios a frenar estas protestas en
cuestión de minutos comenzaron entonces
a desmantelar estos campamentos
alrededor del parlamento que se tomaron
desde el 30 de julio las fuerzas armadas
iraquíes respondieron levantando el
toque de queda y el primer ministro de
irak y mustafa al kadim y afirmó que
dejaría su cargo si la crisis política
continúa lo que deja ver una luz al
final de este estancamiento que vive el
país es de octubre de 2021 para analizar
lo que estaba ocurriendo en irak las
saludamos entonces desde argentina a
italia eres director del núcleo de
estudios de medio oriente de la
universidad austral hay de gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 primero vamos a poner en
contexto a nuestra audiencia
lleva casi 11 meses en elegir un
gobierno precisamente por esta oposición
del bloque sadrista que fue de mayoría
en las elecciones parlamentarias de
octubre del 21 y que ha negado a nombrar
a un presidente que tenga el apoyo de
las corrientes chiquitas respaldadas por
irán cuéntanos entonces más de lo que es
que este estancamiento político en irak
bien habitualmente el re ministro de
irak se elige conforme a una mayoría
calificada para la cual saber y sus
aliados tenían es decir los votos
necesarios sucede que se enfrentan a la
elección del presidente elección de
presidente demanda la formación de
consensos más amplios no porque exige el
quórum de por lo menos dos tercios de
los representantes en el consejo mayoría
con la que asador no cuenta no para
poder facilitar ese quórum los demás
miembros del parlamento exigieron la
humanidad tener un presidente por
consenso en el resultado de la elección
del presidente por consenso sería
también la elección de un primer
ministro y un gabinete por consenso si a
saber especialmente lo que hace es
rechazar esta está esta postura nos dice
bueno o sea nosotros somos el partido
mayoritario tenemos la coalición
mayoritaria no tiene que permitir
postular a nuestro presidente o sea que
la corte
de irak no les ha permitido y no tienes
que además permitir formar el gobierno
cosa que tampoco va a suceder porque
siempre siente finalmente es elegido por
consenso en el mismo paquete entraría
también la elección o el nombramiento
del primer ministro y su gabinete
eso es para realmente la actuación la
opción de crisis si esto es la crisis
entonces esa política pero pues con
demos más un poco de el personaje
digamos hay que inicio pues es todo esto
que estamos viendo en irak estamos
hablando de alzar que tanto poder tiene
en la política incluso ahora que afirmó
que se retiraba
bueno
este golpe de alguna manera demostraba
sanador lo que muestra es su frustración
fue fue una medida inconsulta con sus
aliados de hecho le ha generado le ha
generado
problemas dentro de sus dentro de su
coalición fue que en este contexto de
imposibilidad de imponer un presidente y
de formar gobierno la opción fue
reclamar pedir una reforma del sistema
político
unidad diciendo que este sistema nos
sirve sus aliados se negaron alguna
manera a adherir a esta postura el
primer ministro le reclamó la
radicalidad de sus propuestas el
ministro actual que está en el gobierno
al cadivi no que te una postura mucho
más consensual y frente a esta cuestión
a saber lo que hace que es y político
creo más popular que tiene que tirar lo
ha demostrado las elecciones años
pasados lo están demostrando ahora estas
estas publicaciones lo que ha hecho es
terminar por bueno
esta crisis en la cual a saber se
encuentra solo yo creo que estas
llamadas en los últimos días a pacificar
a decir bueno si no si no terminan los
dos tratamientos no voy a retirar
definitivamente de la política y
pidiendo a sus milicias un poco de calma
fue me parece un gesto sobre actuado en
el cual él decide tomar su vía si
independientemente de sus aliados y
finalmente se encuentra con que el resto
de los que tiene político nos acompañan
esta decisión no claro digamos que es
cuáles son estas estas divisiones más
visibles dentro de los musulmanes
chiítas en irak no y también habladas de
esta reforma política que él quisiera
hacer realmente es posible que se logre
bien vamos a volver a parte
fundamentalmente hay dos grandes
coaliciones políticas e irak una que
tiene una postura más independiente que
es la que es liderada por asador a saber
tener una postura mucho más neutral
frente a teherán está de acuerdo con que
irak e irán tengan un vínculo fuerte
pero no cree que irak tenga que perder
su autonomía frente a irán por estos
temas es partidario del diálogo con
arabia saudita es partidario del diálogo
con los eeuu no tienen problemas de
negociar con nadie
mientras que hay otra coalición la
coalición donde
está fatal y otros partidos como el ex
ministro al malikí que tiene una postura
de alianza no junto con
el gobierno de teherán en el sentido de
que ambas también ambas condiciones
tienen sus propias milicias una palabra
un poco fuerte pero si grupos armados de
alguna manera militantes armados que
responden a uno y otro bando sabiendo
además que esta coalición pro iraní ya
la otra coalición no al avanzado sino la
que se le enfrenta bueno la policía y
las fuerzas armadas responden en general
no a esta línea la influencia de irán en
irak porque esta línea pro iraní en ese
país no que busca
digamos ir a él lo que ha hecho es es
una una
movida regional muy interesante en la
cual ha promovido la creación de
diferentes partidos como diferentes
movimientos como han sido por ejemplo
hezbollah también en el líbano o el
apoyo que le ha dado al fatah donde en
el pressing a donde a hamás perdón y al
fatah en irak donde ha conseguido
diferentes aliados yo creo que acá por
ejemplo una cosa que podemos decir es
que el principal artífice no de él del
desarme de
las tropas
sunitas y regulares no terroristas que
ocuparon en algún momento de irak fueron
estuvieron también estuvieron muy
vinculados a la presencia iraní no o sea
en parte parte de la liberación de irak
tiene que ver digamos de este tipo de
momentos terroristas tiene que ver
también con la presencia militar
fuerzas irregulares que fueron apoyadas
desde ctera con todo este contexto y le
preguntó cómo se puede hacer para
digamos salir de esta tensa situación
política esta crisis política iraquí
digamos en el corto plazo no sé si se
puede hacer en el corto plazo pero pero
como lo ve en el futuro hay que volver
para atrás lo que es lo debe hacer aquí
es
a saber tiene que convencer a sus a sus
militantes para que abandonen las calles
tiene que volver a la mesa de
negociación y la elección presidencial
tendrá que esperar lo que tenga que
esperar hasta que se llegue a una suerte
de consenso lo que él ha pedido se lo
han negado es la realización de
elecciones de nuevas elecciones
parlamentarias no creo que se lo
concedan va a haber que seguir
negociando hasta que se llegue a un
acuerdo este este estatus de
provisionalidad nuestro a la región los
tenemos lo tenemos también de palestina
lo vemos con la formación del gobierno
en el líbano
van a tener que seguir negociando hasta
que finalmente llegue a un acuerdo esto
puede tardar dos años dos años y medio
como tardó la última elección
presidencial en el líbano o por ejemplo
en el caso palestino no se logran poner
de acuerdo en el año 2005 no y todavía
palestina sigue sin un presidente no
electo que hace renovado
en su cargo de forma democrática no